President Joe Biden is seeing His
Highest approval ratings in almost a
year and failed former president Donald
Trump who wants to be president again is
seeing his worst scores among potential
Republican voters in a very long time
this is all according to the latest NPR
PBS NewsHour Marist poll the survey was
conducted after Joe Biden's State of the
Union Address standard poll methodology
what we would expect there are some sort
of trends that are emerging here and
that is of a lack of clarity about Trump
versus DeSantis remember DeSantis hasn't
even announced that he's running for the
Republican nomination but already ahead
of trump in many polls the other element
that we're noticing is that in polling
where it's Trump versus DeSantis that is
better for DeSantis in polling where
it's Trump DeSantis Haley Tim Scott and
other potential candidates more
candidates is better for Donald Trump